welcome back to serverless migration
station where we show google cloud users
one specific migration they can take to
modernize their apps
this is the video for module one
focusing on helping app engine users
switch from web app to flask a popular
web framework in the python community
doing so opens the door to additional
modernization techniques
hi i'm wesley from google here to lead
your journey joined by my colleague
martin
and our little friend porter who will
take you from point a to point b
he was happy to help but why are we
focusing
on web app too i thought app engine
supported many
web frameworks yes that is absolutely
true martin while users
can use other frameworks with app engine
web app 2 comes bundled with
app engine making it the default choice
for many developers and unfortunately
not supported in python 3.
by the way if you've been using a
framework that's not web app you may
actually be in better shape
app engine is now a more flexible
platform so moving away from bundled
services like web app 2 will make users
apps more portable
also flask has more users it has more
resources and is better supported
now flask isn't the only option and
generally any whiskey compliant
framework that does routing is supported
ok so i get it for the web framework uh
but what about all those app engine
bundled service apis well have you heard
of cloud datastore and cloud
tasks well they started out as app
engine datastore and task queues
and since then they've matured to
becoming their own standalone cloud
products where you'll find continuing
new features and innovation
we'll tackle those in other migration
modules but this one focuses just on
flask
all right you said we're going to
migrate a sample app
to flask uh what app well in the module
zero video we gave an overview of the
baseline app we're starting from
so check it out if you missed it okay
i'd like to
follow what you're doing to the code on
my own computer
can you point me to the source code sure
thing martin here's the link
and by the way the repo is maintained
regularly unlike videos
so the code may be newer there let's
pause so all of you can go clone the
repo or download the zip file
got it great let's go to the computer
now and start migrating that module zero
code and turn it into the module one
code
all right let's start from a good place
grab the module zero code from the repo
and deploy to app engine
if you've been around you're probably
expecting to do an app config update
there's a newer and more powerful cli
called gcloud that comes with a cloud
sdk
it gives you access to most cloud tools
instead of just one
so to upload to app engine use gcloud
app deploy
what doesn't change is that your app
should be deployed and available
around the world in less than a minute
starting with the application file
main.py swap the flask imports for web
app 2s
next while web app 2 is initialized at
the bottom with its routing table
you can do it at the top with flask your
app is more complex but these basic
changes apply regardless
next this app only has one route which
goes to main handler
since we already know this you can wipe
the table but when migrating your app
don't delete it quite yet
you'll probably have many more routes
which you need to track so just comment
it out for now once you get to this
point
there's no change to the way we access
datastore the data model and
accompanying rewrite calls stay as is
the handler represents the majority of
the affected code
web app 2 uses the handler classes and
corresponding http methods
in flask a handler is just a route
decorated function like this
finally both frameworks render the
template in a similar way so you just
switch to how flask does it
with that you're done mining grading the
main application
for this migration app.yaml stays the
same
the index.html template file is
identical to the original with one minor
but notable difference
the django style templates that web app
2 uses automatically executes callables
whereas the jinja 2 templating system
that flask uses by default
requires users to explicitly add
parentheses
the datetime c time call turns
timestamps into human readable strings
and that's used in this app to show when
visits occurred
flask also organizes web templates in a
templates folder by default
so create it and move index.html into it
before or after your edit to the c
time column since flask isn't bundled
like web app 2
you must add it to a list of required
packages the baseline app didn't have
any
so create a brand new requirements.txt
file with just flask
now if you're unfamiliar with the
requirements.txt file check out its
documentation
for us the current version is one one
two for a simple app you probably don't
need the version
but in any case the repo is maintained
while this video isn't
meaning you may see a newer version
there
first gen app engine runtimes require
developers to explicitly bundle third
party
for our app it's flask and its
dependencies
so run this pip install command to
install them to the live folder before
you test or deploy
a side effect of bundling third-party
packages is that you need to tell app
engine where to find them
so that's what app engine config dot py
is for
to tell the system to look in lib for
your apps you'll create this file in the
same folder as your application code
just like what we've done with this
sample
the only other files in the repo are
readme and gcloud ignore
neither of which are critical but gcloud
ignore is useful in preventing
unnecessary files to be uploaded and
that's it
hey wes thanks for showing us how to
move to flask watching this video is
great but is there a way for me to do
that migration by hand on my own time
on that sample app before migrating my
own code
well i'm glad you asked martin yes in
addition to this video we have a
corresponding google code lab codelabs
are free online self-paced hands-on
tutorials
so you can do this same migration on
your own time
the repo links you to the code lab the
starting module zero code
as well as the finished module one code
if you get stuck you can always go back
to module 0 or compare your solution to
module 1
to see where you may have gotten off
course for your convenience
here are the docs to both frameworks so
that you can compare and contrast and
better understand the differences
between them
now that you've shown us how to unlink
part of our app from dedicated app
engine libraries uh like
web app two framework uh what's next was
well the module zero app used both
web app 2 and the ndb library to talk to
datastore
now that we're done with the framework
part we're going to be focused on moving
from
ndb to cloud ndb so be sure to join us
for that
this is wesley from google cloud on
behalf of martin and porter
thanks for tuning in today and we look
forward to seeing you at the next
serverless migration station as well as
on other serverless expeditions